descendu pamiers
est à mes côtés
m
lorsqu'il s'agit de musique tout devient
si harmonieux est évident en dresser
mois genton de la même voie jusqu'au
jour où la lettre arrivée
martha
rien ne saurait me faire plus plaisir
que de pouvoir à nouveau chanter à tes
côtés
alors vous formez un genre des diot elle
a surtout été mon grand amour mais je
n'ai jamais osé lui avouer je décidé
d'exprimer tout mon amour et mon
désespoir dans une chance
écoute moi vivons je dois absolument
donner cette chanson à mana il faut
qu'elle sache que je laime mais voilà
on
à
marc raboy entendre cette chanson et je
vais te conduire est un prophète
nous retrouverons m'a pas pour lui
offrir quelques arrivées monde ils
adorent ça selon ces niveaux c'est un
nouveau sommet yabi c'est un kata joue à
face est un fleuve us photo so
[Musique]
foot et quoi encore il faut faire face
savoir improviser
et maintenant
c'est trop con
[Musique]
ouah
à
mais pas qu'entre temps
[Musique]
tu comptes faire quoi j'en sais rien
mais un musicien c'est un
provisionnement c'est un naufrage
des liens puissants et solide chez nous
c'est comme ça
c'est amour gabriela
vivra éternellement dans ton coeur
non
capi